quand vous ou vos enfants allez sur
youtube
avez vous remarqué que ce site
recommande toujours des vidéos des
vidéos qui peuvent même s'enchaîner
automatiquement les unes après les
autres
notre collègue des fillettes s'est
intéressé de près aux mécanismes
derrière ces recommandations il analysé
des milliers et des milliers de
résultats différents
ce qu'il a trouvé nous démontre
l'influencent de youtube sur les choix
de contenu qu'on visionne et tout ça
peut prendre des proportions
inquiétantes pour nos démocraties comme
le prouve d'ailleurs le cas du brésil ce
géant du sud qui s'est retrouvé avec un
président d'extrême droite au terme
d'une élection atypique ou youtube a
beaucoup pesé dans la balance
il ya mille et une façons de suivre une
campagne électorale vous pouvez le faire
via la télé vous pouvez donc contrôler
entièrement et totalement ce que vous
voyez comment vous vous informez
meilleur beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde qui s'informent ou via internet et
notamment youtube où là c'est tout le
contraire c'est pas vous qui avez le
contrôle c'est en quelque sorte un robot
alors jeff avant d'aller plus loin dans
cette conversation là il faut vraiment
vraiment vraiment qu'on explique c'est
quoi un algorithme c'est ce qui guide to
finalement sur youtube à la maison
lorsqu'on écoute la télévision c'est
nous qui zappe non sur youtube par
contre comme s'il y avait une télévision
avec des dizaines de millions de chaînes
différentes épouses et des lada b you
tube a mis au point ce qu'on appelle
l'algorithme de recommandation en
quelque sorte comme robots assistants
s comme si quelqu'un dans votre salon
vous disais bon vous regardez leurs
acquis à tel poste lié le baseball
peut-être que ça vous intéresserait leur
bout vous ne vous font pas
nécessairement seulement des choses en
lien avec le sujet que vous voulez
regarder mon des choses qui vont vous
amener votre attention parce que depuis
longtemps vous passez sur youtube postée
du tout c'est de l'argent avec
si les sauces à cause des problèmes
parce que au problème l'année dernière
par exemple des controverses qu'elle
algorithmes de robots assistants de
youtube montrait des vidéos conflits
raciaux nist les théories dangereuse des
discours et non parce que 6 à 4
l'attention donc on pouvait rechercher
du contenu qui tout à fait inoffensif
il se veut trouver sur des vidéos
complètement dangereux parce que
l'europe aux assistants nous avait dit
peter hickson réécouter ça et tu es
intéressé à ça justement un contexte m
de la tente à la mosquée de québec ans
que youtube faisait dans ce genre de
situation ça donne un cours dans ce
qu'on avait constaté c'est que y avait
plusieurs vous considérez jeunesse qui
s'étaient glissés là dedans que le robot
mettait mettre de l'avant des vidéos on
est sur des théories à propos de
l'attentât un qui contredisent ce qui
s'est vraiment passé sa cause problème
si ces idéologues capte l'attention mais
en même temps ça peut nous mener vers
les coins un peu plus sombre de youtube
dont voudrait peut-être pas
nécessairement se retrouver aux yeux de
la pression sur youtube pour que ça
change énormément de pression youtube
montre une certaine volonté à vouloir
attirer les contenus les plus dangereux
par exemple on youtube fait beaucoup de
travail pour être serré les vidéos qui
par exemple discale et les victimes
d'attentats sont des acteurs des choses
comme ça mais est-ce qu'ils ont réglé
tout le problème ça reste à voir ouais
parce que là on a essayé justement au
décryptage de voir jusqu'à quel point
youtube a compris et à changer
réellement la façon de procéder ce que
quelques mois plus tard on peut dire que
oui
bonne question bref avec une équipe de
six missions s'est penché sur l'élection
canadien donc on a regardé dit des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
vidéos recommandé par youtube
à propos de l'élection canadienne est ce
qu'on a vu c'est que ben ya beaucoup
beaucoup moins de conspiration un
acquiescement pop genre de nouvelles
bonnes choses il n'y a pas de contenu
haineux n'ont plus vraiment dans les
milliers de vidéos qu'on a regardé très
peu ce qu'on a remarqué par contre c'est
que youtube nous reproche de des vidéos
qui n'ont aucun lien avec l'élection
rien à voir rien à voir par exemple
l'une des vidéos les plus populaires qui
ont été recommandés une vidéo qu'ils
aient les des choses les plus étranges
trouver dans l'est dans les fonds sous
marins dont aucun aucun lien avec avec
l'élection ce qu'on peut se poser c'est
que on a modifié l'algorithme pour nous
des vidéos populaires le problème avec
ça c'est que ben de plus en plus de gens
surtout des jeunes qui utilisent youtube
pour s'informer
donc si de la galerie travail qu'on nous
on recherche de l'information et
l'algorithme a dit non écoute pas son
écoute ça à la place donc ça ça soulève
bien des questions par rapport au
pouvoir de calyon et sa force une
réflexion si on veut s'informer
réellement une campagne électorale
jusqu'à quel point on doit aller sur des
outils comme youtube autres je vous
conseille vraiment d'aller voir le
dossier jeff et de nos collègues l'asim
ici sur le site des décrypteurs tout est
là vraiment jeff nous expliquer les
effets des changements portés à
l'algorithme de youtube
il les a testées lui-même par exemple
voici le top 5 des connus recommandé par
youtube quand on effectue une recherche
sur juste être dos et le black fais rien
à voir mais c'est bon à savoir quand on
sait que youtube à thiers 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs mensuels dans le monde et
que les plus jeunes générations
s'informent de plus en plus sur cette
plateforme
mais ça file ce que leur réservent
l'algorithme de youtube
ce que suggère généralement le gard et
de youtube quant aux fans de notre cher
justin trudeau blackface de notre homme
edward claudine profil est un peu
controversé billets 45 kg si
certainement trio tu partes
c'est un monde plus propre parce parce
que ça peut nous amener au savon
d'autres réflexions voire donc qu'est-ce
que ça rapport à votre profil à vous non
c'est une bonne question parfois denses
que si faut pas se fier à tous que les
réseaux sociaux ni non je ne te
reconnais pas être suggérer quelque
chose plutôt choisir de piste moi même
ce que vous faisiez le contenu que vous
recommande d'algorithmes de youtube
brillent habituellement vie satz à rabat
que l'algorithme est une orientation
politique que ce soit détournée sur qui
saviem allumer une lumière et s'allume
et lumière aussi dans l'esprit du
français guillaume chalot ex ingénieur
chez youtube qui a constaté de
l'intérieur ce qu'il appelle le
potentiel toxique des algorithmes de
recommandations du géant du web
ce jeune spécialiste en intelligence
artificielle a calculé que 70% des
vidéos vues sur youtube le sont via son
algorithme
un constat qui dénoncent maintenant sur
toutes les tribunes
alors monsieur chat loaded nous à quel
moment à partir de quand vous êtes rendu
compte qu'il y avait un problème avec
l'algorithme de youtube a commencé très
tôt c'est à dire que par design on
voyait que l'algorithme elle est
toujours vous pousser dans dans ce que
vous aimez déjà n'a jamais été conçu
pour essayer de vous faire découvrir des
choses nouvelles
il a été conçu pour vous donner plus de
la même chose
les algorithmes ont été design et pour
maximiser le temps que vous perdez sur
internet en fait une fois vous avez fait
ce constat qu'est ce que vous avez pu
faire par la suite
la mentalité de google sait si vous
voyez quelque chose qui est cassé
ne vous plaignez pas fixé le en fait on
n'a pas envie d'être le râleur de
services donc du coup les gens
s'autocensurent donc moi ce que j'ai
fait c'est que j'ai essayé de trouver
des solutions sans me plaindre donc
montrer qu'il ya d'autres algorithmes
qui peuvent permettre aux gens de de
sortir de leur bulle en fait et les
algorithmes jusqu'à quel point ça peut
représenter un danger ça oui c'est
dangereux parce que du coup on se rend
pas compte des problèmes structurels et
qui vont exploser un jour par exemple le
problème de pédophilie ou l'algorithme a
recommandé des vidéos de petites filles
dans des positions inappropriée des
millions de personnes donc ça c'est un
problème qui aurait pu être résolu des
années des années avant et malgré tout
ça est ce qu'il ya quand même une lueur
d'espoir à quelques pas à la lueur
d'espoir c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui commencent à prendre conscience du
problème
on a vu sur extrémisme la radicalisation
les gens ont pris conscience que les
plateformes jouer un rôle n'était pas
neutre par rapport à cette
radicalisation
et il ya eu énormément de pression qui a
été mise et il eu des actions qui ont
été prises par les plateformes le
problème c'est que on a très peu de
visibilité sur ce qui se passe sur
youtube
moi ce que je veux c'est dire aux gens
qu'il faut qu'on sache dans quelle
direction va
que tout le monde puisse savoir dans
quelle direction les algorithmes nous
pousse pour voir collectivement sur vais
dans la bonne direction
[Musique]